hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
khan starts out the groundwork of the
metaphysics of morals by saying that
there's only one thing in the universe
that we can say is genuinely always
completely good and that is the good
will the way he actually puts it
is a little bit funny because he says
there's one good thing
without qualification is how we've
typically translated it and that by
itself is already in a way a
qualification you're qualifying you know
precisely how it's good but he says
there's only one good thing without
qualification
in the entire universe and that is the
good will not necessarily the human will
but any rational
will that's that's good
and he says it's impossible to conceive
anything at all in the world or even out
of it which can be taken as good without
qualification except a good will so it's
not just that we that's the only thing
we encounter
he's saying that this is the only thing
we could actually conceive of
and that might throw you for a loop
because you can think of a lot of good
things
and so you might say to yourself well
you know what about wealth people pursue
wealth or what about honor what about
virtue what about all these other
candidates for
the good what about pleasure
what about peace of mind although those
sorts of things
so kant is not saying that we can't ever
think of other things and understand
them to be good he's saying if we if we
completely think it through from his
perspective
the only thing that then we can conceive
of as being
truly good
is the good will so how can this be well
he looks at a number of different
candidates at the beginning
another bunch of other possibilities for
what could be good
and he says why they're not actually the
good
so talents of mind what do we mean by
this he gives you a few examples
wit is among
them by which he doesn't mean just
being witty being funny or anything like
that but being able to connect things
together
intelligence being able to think things
through
being able to draw conclusions being
able to reflect on things
judgment
the capacity to
to judge well when it comes to difficult
matters
those are good things
but like he says
these can be extremely bad and hurtful
when the will is not good which is going
to make use of these so that's a
really central thing the will itself
is what decides to
make use of these it decides what's
going to happen with them
so great intelligence for example can be
used for evil as well as for for good
wit even in the sense of humor can be
used to
bring a community together it can be
used to tear people down
judgment you know figuring out precisely
the right place to hit the person so as
to cause the greatest pain that could be
a matter of judgment but that doesn't
sound like something that we'd always
say is you know representative of the
good will that's more like something a
sadist would do isn't it
so talents of mind are not going to
be the the pri the ultimate good or the
primal good
what about
qualities of
temperament
when we talk about somebody's character
their personality the way that they are
kant has some examples of these he says
for example courage
resolution
constancy of purpose these are all three
related to each other by the way
courage is the capacity to
stand up for
the difficult good as thomas put it or
in the face of fear as
aristotle thought about it um and khan
has something similar in in mind
um constancy of purpose once you've
actually once you've actually decided on
something sticking to it what we call
perseverance
resolution being able to actually
set yourself upon something and you
notice those are
not only qualities of one's temperament
some people have them more some people
have them less
but those are things that we can develop
and those are things that we would
attribute to somebody's will you know
perseverance is something of the will
but by themselves these things again if
the will is not good they can be used
for for harm for bad
so the bank robber who
has great courage
and
executes some daring feats you know
breaking into the vault shooting up a
bunch of police
you know making everything go into the
last minute we wouldn't say that
person's good
in any sort of unqualified sense
so
that's not going to be
that's not going to be the ultimate good
what about gifts of fortune here we're
getting to external goods things that
well and also some of the body
things that people just happen to have
if they're lucky and then they they get
taken away or they don't have them if
they're unlucky
so you know what would be examples of
these
power wealth honor
even health and then kant says that
complete well-being and contentment with
one state that goes by the name of
happiness these he sees all as sort of
well you get them or you don't get them
it's kind of luck of the draw
you can work you know to some degree to
have them but some people are healthier
some people are less healthy
whether you're happy or not depends on a
lot of different things coming together
that's not the good either
for kant
why not he says well you know
if you don't have a good will these
things are actually liable to spoil you
they're liable to make you identify
with the good things that you have and
to think that they're somehow you know
about you or connected with you and
you're liable to you know become in some
ways prideful about them
if you don't have a good will
the other thing that goes along with it
he says is
a rational impartial spectator can never
feel approval in contemplating the
uninterrupted prosperity of being graced
by no touch of a pure and good will and
so you know somebody who for instance is
wealthy but they're they're a bad person
an impartial observer will look at that
and they're not going to be happy about
that and khan thinks that that that
intuition there is something to pay
attention to
what about some things that might be a
little bit closer what he calls
qualities that are helpful
to the good will
they make its task very much easier he
says
they have nonetheless no in inner
unconditioned worth but rather
presuppose a
good will
which sets a limit to the esteem in
which they're rightly held
and does not permit us to regard them as
absolutely good so
even those are not going to be
unqualifiedly good even though they they
allow the good will to do its work
better
what are some examples of these well
some of the things that we we look at as
being either the virtues or something
like the virtues so
moderation in affections and passions
moderation in in dealing with
our
desires
our emotions
being able to set certain limits upon
ourselves to keep ourselves within those
limits
self-control
that's another one that he brings up
sober reflection doesn't necessarily
mean sober in terms of drinking but
sober in the sense of
being in one's full mind and having this
this
practice of thinking things through and
he says
these may actually seem to constitute
part of the inner worth of a person so
there as opposed to some of these things
we're actually getting very close to
what makes a person a good person
but not all the way there
those are not the good will either
the good will
is what has to be
motivating
uh embodied within directing all of
these other things
so
what does that leave us well
let's think now
here's the second question we have to
ask
what makes that will good
what are some possibilities what are
some candidates for that
and if we're looking at other moral
theories one of the things that we would
think of right off the bat would be
what we call effects
or
consequences
a good will is one that leads to good
beneficial
happiness producing effects either for
oneself or for other people this is what
utilitarianism would say this is what
what hedonism would say what egoism
would say
even you know to certain to a certain
extent virtue ethics is willing to say
that consequences matter
so
could it be that
kant says
no it's not good because of what it
affects or accomplishes
so it's not the action
and its effects
that the will
leads to that that make it good
that would be to measure the will by
something else instead you want to look
at the will directly
he says
it's fitness for attaining some proposed
end that's not going to work
why what makes this will good
it is good through its willing alone
that is good in itself
and then he's got some sort of laudatory
language here you know it's esteemed
beyond comparison and all that but you
want to think about this for for a
moment um
even if
the will to do something
something that's good is ineffectual
it's not able to bring about what it is
that the person is willing to do that's
a good volition that's a good willing
that person's will is good in that
respect
what makes that will good so if it's not
what it brings about
which is the consequences of the action
actually let's sort of chart this out we
have consequences
we have effects
let's remove all of this
what leads us there the
action itself
and what produces the action
willing something leads to the
action hopefully unless something goes
wrong
which leads to the effects and
consequences
kant is saying we're not going to look
at this
and
we're not even
necessarily looking at this so much
we're looking at
you might there's sort of an overlap
here we're looking at this the willing
itself
what are you willing
you're choosing how to use
your own
freedom
in relation to a world in which you
exist your desires
and you're choosing when you're choosing
an action you're not just choosing one
specific thing to do that leads to real
consequences
you're choosing you might say
the
genre
of action the type of of action
that's what you're actually
willing as such and that's what's making
the will good
in part there's one other thing that's
going to come in here what's missing
here
well
your motive
and what you know your motive could be
aiming at some sort of effect in that
case that's not going to make the will
good by itself
the motive can permeate
the willing the act of willing itself
and the type of action that it is
one can will something like
i want to do the sort of thing that a
person with a good will
would do
and that is leading us to the very end
of this because we'll go into other core
concepts where we deal with that what is
that
what motive
is it that leads us to will the right
thing for the right reason
it's to fulfill
what kant is going to call as many other
people have
duty
duty for its own sake willing duty for
the sake of willing duty not for some
other motive not to bring about some
sort of effect necessarily but because
it is and it embodies the right thing
that's what
conditions that's what reveals to us the
good will